if I was a Russian I would be more
worried about China than I would be by
the United States or Western Europe or
Ukraine
so here we are discussing the supposed
decline relative decline of the West and
Rise of China and maybe India but
actually the actions of China and Russia
in particular recently have strengthened
the West so you've laid out how China's
actions have brought new allies to the
Western Taiwan what Putin has done has
strengthened NATO and our Sweden and
Finland joining NATO and the West seems
much more united have we actually got
this wrong well you know if I was a
Russian I would be more worried about
China than I would be by the United
States or Western Europe or Ukraine why
because Russia is a declining power many
people see this vast area of Russia the
population of Russia Today is 150
million which is the same in France and
Germany combined its GDP is much the
same as Italy or the Netherlands
someday in the 19th century
said that Russia has only two friends
during thesaurus period it's Army and
its Navy
somebody recently said Russia Today has
only two friends it's oil in its gas
and it's gas of course it's no longer
selling to Europe so if I was a Russian
I would know because it's self-evident
neither America nor Europe has a claim
against a single square inch
or centimeter of Russian territory
that is not the same as is necessarily
going to be the case of China with
Russia
we know a city called Vladivostok on the
far East of Siberia about 10 million out
of 150 million are the only people who
live in that part of perhaps 15 million
who live in that part of the Russian
Federation it's a huge empty space
where Vladivostok is that whole region
was part of China part of the Chinese
Empire until
1867 when it was forced when it was weak
the time of seeding Hong Kong to Britain
and making other concessions to others
it was forced to seed that territory to
Russia so although we don't hear about
that at the moment
we know that Russia because it's so weak
at the moment it relies on China
to buy its oil and gas it relies on
China to support it diplomatically
because nobody else does worth nothing
uh and it's having to make major
concessions in terms of its own economic
interests and its own political
interests so one day there will be a
Statesman in Russia rather than a
dictator
who will not be an enemy of China but
will say look
that's the country we have to deal with
because it's the only country in the
world that is likely to claim large
chunks of Russia in the foreseeable
future can I add just a little bit to
this because you actually as we look
around the world although Putin is
actually bragging in the fact that the
vast majority of the world's population
uh you know actually more supportive of
Russia than maybe a passive sense from
either abstaining from U.N resolutions
there is already a very strong feeling
particularly in some of the brics
countries you know for example Brazil
and even in South Africa that Russia's
declined dramatically as a result of the
war
uh my colleagues I at Brookings uh
recently had a uh a series of
discussions with some Brazilian
counterparts and the the Brazilians are
actually more likely to see the war in
Ukraine as a proxy war between the US
and China than they were between the US
and Russia because they see Russia was
already dependent on China in the ways
that samalkam has described here and
this was just before President Lula went
on his visit to China and they said that
Lula wanted to hear what the Chinese
thought about the uh the war in Ukraine
not really what the Russians wanted to
see and that they were already seeing
Russia declining as an economic uh
partner as well apart from in fertilizer
for example because the Brazilians don't
buy a lot of Russian oil and obviously
uh and obviously gas and if you start to
kind of you know look around just as
samalcum is saying you know Russia
definitely does not have the moral High
Ground on this despite you know what
appears to be some you know support for
Putin people are very happy to have
Russian money particularly in the Gulf
at the moment because you know Russian
oligarchs are moving their money from
the cypresses and all the other kind of
players they used to have it and into
Dubai but they're just seeing
opportunity out of this they're not
necessarily seeing this
um as you know new sets of partnership
ships so I think you know just exactly
as Malcolm has said we're going to see
Russia in a very different place and the
demographics is very important here too
because just as other countries have now
seeing their populations Rising uh the
Russian population is going to decline
even further as a result of the wharf it
really is the case that in Bahamut alone
as Mr pregosian the head of the Wagner
group has said that the Russians have
lost 20 000 men and you already have you
know a couple of hundred thousand as
we're hearing in other statistics
disabled in some fashion and you've got
1.3 million Russians who have left to
either avoid the drafter because they
don't want to be part of the war you can
start doing the math because these are
the younger most Progressive parts of
the population we've seen over every
major conflict a massive drop in
population so we've always seen that in
Ukraine as well we're going to see that
in Russia too so we're much more likely
to see a different configuration going
ahead you know whether Putin thinks he's
won this or can last everyone out he's
completely and utterly destroying the
future of Russia for some you know
considerable period of time which is not
to say that Russia won't be with us I
think that's you know quite the contrary
but it will not be the same Russia in
terms of a kind of a more positive force
a demographically economically and
politically that it could have been in
the past for sure
very short points China's position on
Ukraine is much more interesting than
they sometimes realized first of all it
has never despite being Putin's closest
Chum China has never voted with Russia
to support what Russia has done in
Ukraine it's always abstained and
refused to recognize the annexation of
Ukrainian territory but the most
interesting thing you will all recall
how a few months ago there was deep
concern that tactical nuclear weapons
might be used by Russia to put pressure
on Ukraine and on the west now no one
can rule that out but it seems to have
gone away and if it has gone away the
single most important reason would have
been a conversation Xi Jinping had with
Putin when he said if you ever think of
using technical nuclear weapons we will
condemn you as will India and in other
countries but the more then why is China
saying that not because it is a nice
bunch of guys concerned with nuclear
weapons what China is deeply worried is
if a non-nuclear state like Ukraine was
successfully blackmailed by a nuclear
weapon state like Russia and got away
with it
who would be tempted to go the same way
Japan South Korea Taiwan all of whom are
non-nuclear and all of whom have the
capacity to develop nuclear weapons if
they so chose and that is why China
fortunately on this issue its own
interests coincide with the same views
of the vast majority of the world
interesting can I yes on this can I just
come in on this point China Russia
relations and you mentioned vladivastok
Uh Russian Far East is where I spent a
lot of time doing research in Siberia
and crossing the border between Russia
and China
so when Putin came to power the what he
had announced was first he said the
collapse of the Soviet Union was the
greatest geopolitical catastrophe of the
21st 20th century 20th century and then
he said the development of the Russian
Far East is the biggest geopolitical
priority for the Russian State because
the if you take Siberia and the Russian
Far East that's roughly two-thirds of
Russia's territories and very small
population currently because of the
ongoing immigration from the Far East to
the European Parts about six six and a
half million populations have
participated a number of conferences in
the Far East about demo how to solve
demographic problems and they try to
bring in they are afraid of Chinese
migrants taking over but now the Chinese
are not going as labor migrants because
they have plenty of jobs in China so
then they're afraid they try to bring in
Vietnamese workers who went to Moscow
and European parts then Putin signed a
deal with Modi invited Modi this to
annual conference in the Russian Far
East to bring Indians but Indians will
not go anywhere so it's too cold and so
many problems so so the Russian Far East
is completely neglected and China has
effectively uh been acquiring control so
a lot of Russian opposition leaders
kadarkovski Maxim Katz and many others
have been talking about how Putin has
completely sold out uh to China and
Israel Russia has become a vassal state
of China and China is seeking to restore
the humiliation in the 19th century when
the Border was demarcated where a lot of
these areas which are now part of
Russian Federation were actually Chinese
and China still vladivastoke and all
these places China still uses the
Chinese names to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas